[Musique]
bienvenue à l'école ashton fly basée à
toussus-le-noble chaque année une
centaine d'étudiants sont formés au
pilotage à présentation
pour connaître l'école sous toutes ses
coutures je suis avec le directeur
frédéric frédéric depuis quand été créé
l'école bonjour l'école a été créé en
2003 sous le nom de r & company et cette
école donc a évolué de 2003 jusqu'en
2014 pour devenir ashton fly où elle est
devenue la première école de pilotage
privé en france est aujourd'hui en 2019
nous continuons à assurer cette position
de leader par un nombre de formations
professionnelles et privées très
important justement quelles sont les
formations vous proposer ici alors
majoritairement les formations que nous
proposons sont des formations qui permet
devenir pilote professionnel
quand on dit pilote professionnel c'est
avoir la capacité après l'obtention de
sa licence de devenir pilote dans une
compagnie aérienne dans une compagnie
d'affaires ou de devenir instructeur
dans une école comme sean fly le
deuxième type de formation qui est
proposé ce sont les brevets de pilote
privé qui permettent pour du loisir de
louer des avions et de partir en
villégiature se faire plaisir quand le
temps le permet et quand l'envié
présentes et les formations sont très
rapides 1 18 mois alors effectivement
une formation professionnelle dure au
minimum 18 mois je dis bien au minimum
parce que c'est un investissement fort
de la part de l'élève qui va être en
deux étapes une étape de 9 mois qui
concerne la partie théorique et une
étape de 9 mois qui concerne la partie
pratique durant ce cursus de 18 mois
toute la formation est dispensée chez
aston fly à toussus le noble et seuls
deux semaines sont réalisées à
l'étranger en partenariat avec une
société qui s'appelle simtek pour faire
un module de travail en équipage
dix-huit mois c'est pas trop court alors
18 mois c'est intensif ce n'est pas trop
court il faut bien comprendre que ce
sont des formations professionnelles
donc pendant ce cursus de 18 mois les
neuf premiers mois il y a à peu près une
semaine de congés seulement les prévu et
l'activité des élèves se fait du lundi
au vendredi exclusivement le prix de
l'école le prix de cette formation
professionnelle aujourd'hui aston fly le
propose à 105 1500 euros
c'est le prix du marché actuellement
pour des écoles de notre notoriété et de
la taille de nos infrastructures
actuelles l'objectif d'asseoir fly c'est
quoi c'est de grandir encore plus alors
nous avons une prévision de croissance
de telle manière que nous soyons en
mesure de former 120 élèves théorique à
l'année + 120 élèves pratique uniquement
pour cette formation professionnelle
actuellement sur 2019 nous sommes nous
ne sommes qu'à 90 élèves et donc c'est
une croissance quand même de 33% qui va
encore s'organiser sur l'année 2020 de
nombreux cours sont donnés en anglais
comme on a pu le voir lors de la
conférence pourquoi alors ce ne sont pas
de nombreux cours tous les cours sont
donnés en anglais tout simplement
pourquoi parce que ses pilotes auront
vocation lorsqu'ils auront leur licence
à rentrer dans des compagnies ou la
langue naturelle d'emploi et l'anglais
et dont nous avons fait le challenge le
pari que si nos élèves veulent réussir
nous devons leur maître les meilleures
installations et les meilleurs niveaux
d'apprentissage disponibles dès le
premier jour est donc tout est en
anglais
les livres les professeurs parlent
anglais ils auront durant leur formation
un taux etc qui leur sera proposé en
plus des diplômes nécessaires qui
doivent passer et où est ce qu'ils
trouvent un emploi après alors
actuellement la licence qui va leur être
délivrée suite à la réussite à leur
examen théorique et pratique va leur
permettre de travailler dans 89% des
compagnies du monde mondial
la licence et asa et la licence la mieux
répandu en termes de qualité c'est la
plus difficile et c'est celle qui permet
quand vous l'avez de pouvoir aller
parcourir le monde sans aucune
difficulté
merci beaucoup frédéric on va maintenant
rencontrer à des élèves
[Musique]
je suis maintenant avec l'un des élèves
de l'école nicolas nicolas alors
pourquoi vous êtes lancés dans cette
filière alors je me suis lancé dans
cette filière principalement parce que
2-1 l'aviation c'était ma passion depuis
tout petit j'ai commencé l'aéronautique
à 18 ans par lui-même et au fil des
années dont j'ai fait une formation
commerciale initialement j'ai travaillé
pendant deux à trois ans et ensuite je
me suis dit que c'était bon moment pour
me lancer en tant que pilote commercial
dans les rucks qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous avez choisi cette école plutôt
qu'une autre en sachant que cette école
et privé tout à fait donc l'école est
privé ce qui a déterminé mon choix c'est
que de 1 gbit sur paris donc c'était une
école qui était proche de paris et en
termes d'investissements ce soit sur les
avions les avions étaient propres
la flotte d'avions et bien entretenus
alors les cours sont en anglais c'est
assez intensif
comment on fait pour réussir son diplôme
ici alors beaucoup travaillé c'est le
maître mot c'est beaucoup de travail
la formation théorique dure neuf mois en
anglais et oui ça demande beaucoup de
ressources à la fois pour entendu si on
n'est pas nette de l'anglais s'habituer
à ça parce que c'est pas non plus inné
de tout de suite comprendre comprendre
l'anglais et surtout que c'est très
technique
donc voilà seulement l'investissement à
la fois en cours également après les
cours et maintenant je suis avec pauline
qui n'a pas encore terminé ses études il
lui reste trois mois
c'est tout à fait ça il me reste cinq
certificats à passer sur 14
donc normalement fort mais je pourrais
débuté la formation pratique en fait la
formation théorique dure neuf mois donc
c'est par phases de trois mois donc
trois mois de cours pour à peu près cinq
certificats une semaine d'examens et
c'est reparti pour trois mois de cours
une semaine d'examens
pour les courses avarie on peut aussi
bien avoir une semaine du lundi au
samedi et on peut avoir deux jours de
cours par semaine
et qu'est ce qui donne envie justement
de se lancer dans un métier comme celui
là vous par exemple moi c'est grâce à
mes deux grands pères à mon père qui
sont dans ce milieu là j'ai toujours
baigné dedans et j'ai toujours voulu en
faire ma vie et depuis tout petit donc
aujourd'hui j'essaye de réaliser mon
rêve est aussi un but le but d'une vie
il ne vous reste plus que quelques mois
à tenir merci beaucoup pauline pour se
perfectionner les élèves peuvent
utiliser une trentaine d'appareils donc
ça permet d'avoir un bon turnover et
donc d'assurer à l'élève une formation
en continu la formation est fait sur des
avions de dernière génération est
actuellement les compagnies demandent
des formations sur ce type d'avion avec
ce type d'écran la prochaine rentrée est
programmée au mois de juin à si vous
voulez plus d'informations une journée
portes ouvertes est organisée le 16 mars
prochain ici à toussus le noble
[Musique]